[Musique]
aujourd'hui j'ai envie d'escapade ma vie
escape et m'a dit faire un escape game
quoi ici au château de blois lui un
escape game qui nous permet de délivrer
marie de médicis qui a été emprisonné
ici pour nos deux ans par son fils louis
xiii ouest et diouf à l'époque denis le
garde du je m'attends à l'intérieur afin
de m'expliquer les règles de neeskens
games et demain filtrer auprès des
partisans du roi afin de délivrer mary
mary barry
et de me voilà à mon avis dans une des
salles de bal du château de blois mon
avis c'est ici que richelieu faisait du
stand up à l'époque alors attention
parce qu'à l'époque quand tu faisais du
stand-up j'avais intérêt de drôle si tu
étais pas drôle je faisais taper par
henri de lorraine duc de guise dit le
balafré n'était pas drôle aux coups de
bâton quoi direct à mon avis richelieu
idée faire des vannes comme ça bienvenue
au château de blois
celui qui conduit c'est celui qui ne
doit pas
bon à la vaissière cabinet
c'est quoi cette blague à trois sous ça
nous a pas fait rire vous ça va me fait
rire ça oui maintenant normalement le
bâton de duba la trinité pas pointu
comme ça là c'est trop pointu la 2016
ces points stimulé ça stimulant toi tu
as mis en place un escape game autour de
l'histoire de l'évasion de marie de
médicis marie médicis doit partir à doit
à doit fuir le château mais c'est pas
chose facile parce que elle doit faire
ça avec la complicité du duc d'epernon
mai mais le roi louis xiii envoyé ces
espions ils surveillent le duc d'epernon
alors c'est moi le garde moi je suis un
des des pistons du duc d'epernon moi je
suis là pour faire en sorte que ça
marche dès lors le jeu ici oui il
consiste en quoi on va accueillir les
joueurs on va leur présenter l'histoire
on va leur présenter ce château qui est
comme un lieu extraordinaire
d'histoire on va les emmener dans un des
appartements du château l'appartement
potentiellement d'une des pernaut le
conflit des marines médicis et la halle
aventure commence c'est parti pour le
début de l'aventuré c'est par l'harmonie
aux halles et stimule on a bâché
stimulons ça forcément là on ira plus
vite en
pop up up derrière cette porte c'est
l'histoire de france avant de rentrer il
faut savoir certaines choses pour
pouvoir délivrer la reine ce soir il
faudra neuf objets une fois que vous
aurez les neuf objets vous aurez le mot
de passe alors uniquement à ce moment là
vous pourrez à 23h59 délivrer la reine
petits détails en cas d'échec c'est la
pendaison
[Musique]
allez-y messi rentre
marine médicis a dû laisser des indices
marie de médicis aimait beaucoup les
pierres précieuses les joailleries
choses comme ça et je crois qu'il y à
son atelier avec sa boîte à bijoux ça va
certainement être utile mais alors les
gens une fois qu'ils ont terminé ce jeu
est ce qu'ils retiennent des
informations d'histoire où est-ce qu'ils
sont là juste pour s'amuser justement
les deux dans un sens car dans le droit
d'entrée les joueurs peuvent visiter le
château et c'est un excellent complément
pour voir les personnages emblématiques
qui ont vécu ici il ya des rois qui ont
vécu à blois loup 12 françois 1er on
peut dire que ce sont les deux
personnages emblématiques qui ont fait
de boire une ville importante et ça ça
compte
dans des montres des diamants et tout
rigolo comme trace avec
[Musique]